welcome to this video against HSK from
Finland so and he's playing them four
nights okay yeah I don't have a great
don't have a great line against that
actually I have to admit that a plate
this a bit too quick now didn't want
that exactly but okay the 94 mph this is
one of those this is one of my back up
lines like if I forget everything I can
play that but of course it seems that
why it is a bit a bit better in this
position with D for a will gain some
space in the center okay so can I go a
five year maybe this is an idea winning
some space threatening be 5a for winning
a P so he has to react to a five a
little bit at least threatening a form
okay hmm Bishop to e6 maybe I'm not not
sure about this that might have been
mostly weakening what I did there with a
five before seems a bit bit tricky Jim I
don't want to take that's clear if I
take it he's opening up the sea fowl and
so that's not a good idea and night is
coming to have five in a very strong way
yeah here i was thinking i can just take
maybe let's do that and not think about
it too long I thought that this should
be okay the central play that also makes
the bishop won't be three look a bit bad
yes I know
I was thinking we should be six I am
okay ofE for as well ok let's go age six
first if he goes h4 then I play you for
it should be ok YF night age 70 kh4 is
nonsense anyway I have not aged 7 lock
him after that is his pawns up I bit
overstretched ok ok so he prevents you
form de 94 Queenie for my queen is
hanging on D seven so maybe this one ok
so see preparing that I guess let's
prepare this on my own Bishop g5 on my
own is weird way to put it I mean let's
prepare something for myself let's say
Bishop g5 this is an idea or possibly
Bishop to h4 Bishop g5 now yes let's try
to block this and maybe I get an e for
later it doesn't that's it shouldn't be
too bad for this position
or Cassie does he have something great
yeah like age for firing firing bullets
I don't think so yeah here was thinking
to screen the aid preventing any age for
business oh I didn't see that move at
all but it's not it's not terrible I
then he wants to go age four yeah I see
but well I still have before central
counter would be a bit strange if if you
just if has some porn advanced there
would just be fantastic okay it's not a
move I expected
okay maybe 9 s6 g5 takes takes Knight
age 7 is actually welcomed as he opens
also for me at least that what I think
maybe I'm wrong I mean g6 I don't know
I'm oh it is opening up the rock ends
and stuff and f6 Queenie five should be
good anyway now maybe not maybe the
Queen trade is possible not easy okay
not easy at all and maybe just Rock g1
for some folks even know is taking them
I didn't expect that at all as you roll
okay 95 eat eggs i'm taking a couple of
times mmm not it's not too great yeah
the biggest issue is that he's getting
his bishop into the play that's really a
problem on me maybe I have Queen f6c
symbol takes tanks t6 and I cannot
cannot calculate that
not in with this limited time Queenie
one I wasn't sure takes takes rook
chicks kingi to end my night is hanging
and I don't know my pieces are bit
uncoordinated maybe I could have done
that 94 at the end it's possible but
this is not not without its points if he
takes it rook takes I have various ideas
checks on age six and so on taking c 6-r
take with the queen with check so this
is probably not a terribly bad idea
there are some some ways to really
instantly lose taking on say well we
assume that I thought that would be good
for me okay takes is going Bishop 250
what is he doing ok check HERE can also
check their rookie one rook takes Queen
d5 but Queen g2a saving yeah I can just
check or play here don't know let's
let's play let's play to f6 keeping
Queen f5 in the position the check you
just probably plays King g2 and I don't
see anything great down this is maybe a
bit more bit more demanding
can still check kingi tool no no
particularly great move rookie five is
something i'm a bit varied above my back
rang and that's f4 wait not so fast
how'd you do that
look the a line for the pin I don't know
it look strange yeah I have to play I'm
not seeing something really great
unfortunately
hmm my case really in time in time
travel let me get out of any chicks
there but what what time I am I going to
can keep King e7 this is crazy this is
crazy chick Kings you too maybe I've off
up to be tool that could be an idea
check and then all the way here maybe
this is something and I still doesn't
have a check at the moment one check
they go to age seven no that's not
working
I don't see move wow he's good idea ooh
check me no it's made no I run into a
mate ah Christ ah the only way to lose I
tried to win the thing is I'm not very
practical about those things I still
want to play good moves I mean I can't
just play any nonsense and win on time
that's that's it but I wanted to try to
prank good moves there check yeah true
kia group III was a move check our
position is not good but I didn't find
anything I wanted to play well but I
couldn't really get this get this going
computer gives equal with him Group C
aid I felt I should I felt I should be
okay somehow with his slightly awkward
King position kara this helped me an O
king of eight is a lemon but I couldn't
I couldn't really find something
something dissonant yes the pond there
yeah I didn't see Roxy ate earlier check
and see I am I am really lost right I
have no move yeah I'm just lost that's
very very tricky very tricky position
here here here it was interesting it
really was check oh yeah I can just take
si tu I didn't I do that actually okay I
wanted to take f 5 which is which is
interesting but I could have taken that
I was really not seeing that I'm
attacking the rook yeah that's much
better than also because it takes away
any seafoam and you see for ideas now
okay I was very tricky position thanks
for watching